foreign
this super conducting magnet can do more
than just attract paper clips it could
unlock energy sources that could free
humans from fossil fuels and you are
about to take this miracle of Science
and swallow it whole
wait what
how would it change your DNA
how would this affect your animal
instincts
and how could it make your brain explode
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you swallowed the world's most
powerful magnet
in 2021 a team of MIT researchers
created a magnet strong enough to
recreate the same nuclear fusion
reactions that happen in the sun over
the next few years the tests these
scientists performed could determine the
future of our planet
the energy emitted from this magnet
could revolutionize our power grid and
reduce our carbon emissions
so making this Cutting Edge technology
into your next meal would be pretty
selfish but if you had the power of the
sun inside your stomach what would
happen to your organs
just pinch your nose and relax one
swallow and voila the Earth's magnetic
field comes in at
0.00005 Teslas the measure of magnetic
strength
that souvenir magnet on your fridge
comes in at
0.001 Teslas
but the one floating in your gut
measures a record-breaking 20 Teslas how
are you feeling now
your body already generates a magnetic
field produced by the electrical
currents in your nervous system
doctors even use these currents to map
brain functions
researchers have found that outside
exposure to weak magnetic fields can
affect chemical reactions in your cells
so having this magnet inside of you
could radically alter your DNA
for starters magnetic waves have the
potential of repairing cell damage
faster
imagine if your body could heal from
cancer before you knew you had it
but this comes at a price with these
powerful waves pulsating through your
brain could you even tell which way is
up
every magnet contains two opposite
forces where the charge is the strongest
we call these points the poles these
poles carry an opposite charge to the
other usually referred to as the North
and South Poles
so with this magnet inside you your head
would become the North Pole and your
feet would become the South
the fields coming out could align you
with the Earth's magnetic field
now you could navigate anywhere by
instinct
forget your phone's GPS your senses
would be as strong as birds and whales
that migrate worldwide using those same
magnetic fields
now while you might be in tune with the
natural world your other senses could be
completely rattled
the electric pulses in your nervous
system could be disrupted entirely
making it difficult to move
your brain contains a mineral known as
magnetite made up of iron oxide your
brain tissue could rip apart as these
minerals swirl toward the North Pole in
your head
so if this mineral could gather in
clumps does that mean your body would
become magnetic
well while your Sixth Sense could be
heightened you probably wouldn't be able
to magnetize other metallic objects just
by touching them
just don't go swallowing anything
magnetic
the metals could be drawn to the poles
inside your body and ripped through your
organs
that experiment like your life would be
short-lived and if you got near
something as strong as an MRI machine
which uses a magnetic field to take
images inside the human body the waves
from the machine combined with what is
sitting in your stomach could rip your
body apart it would be really easy to
see what's inside you then
okay well that would be the case if you
gulped down a huge magnet now if you ate
a smaller magnetic strip you might be
able to use your magnetic field to
levitate like a high-speed train does
and then while the rest of us are stuck
in traffic you could be zipping around
the world
so what if instead of that
world-changing magnet you poured
yourself some liquid mercury instead
well step away from the magnet and get
your shot glass because that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]